ام
اهلا بكم انطلقت جلسات الحوار الوطني في
تونس بمشاركه جبهه الانقاذ المعارضه وذلك
بعد تعهد رئاسه الحكومه في رساله ورعاه
الحوار بالاستقاله في غضون ثلاثه اسابيع
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي مناقشه في محورين
ما هي اهداف القوى السياسيه الفاعله في
تونس من وراء حاله الشد والجذب التي سبقت
انطلاق الحوار الوطني
وما هي احتمالات توصل الحوار الى تسويه
تحقق الترابيه بين جميع الاطراف وتؤمن
عمليه التحول الديمقراطي
انفق الحوار الوطني تونسي بعد تعثر
وتجاذبات سياسيه ح يدها ولو مؤقتا كما
يبدو تعهد رئيس الحكومه علي العريض كتاب
رعاه الحوار بالاستقاله وبموجبه اعتبر
جبهه الانقاذ الحكومه في حكم المستقيله في
الوقت الراهن فقررت العوده للحوار الوطني
وقبل النواب المنسحبين من المجلس التاسيسي
العوده للمشاركه في اعماله لكن بقي على
جميع القوى السياسيه التونسيه الاتفاق في
غضون ثلاثه اسابيع على تشكيل حكومه غير
حزبيه وعلى اتمام عمليه صياغه الدستور
وتشكيل لجنه للانتخابات وايضا تحديد جدول
زمني لاجراء انتخابات رئاسيه و نيابيه
لم تعد تونس خضراء وحسب
الاحمر اذا قدموا في سيدي بوزيد مهد
الثوره العرب تاجل الحوار الوطني وكان
يفترض ان عقد الاربعاء وساد انعدام الثقه
بين الحكومه ومعارضيها اصبح الشارع حقلا
للتجارب بينهما قطر المعارضه ضد حزب
النهضه فتخرج الاخيره الى الشارع دفاعا عن
الشرعيه تتطور الامور اكثر فتشترط
المعارضه تعهدا واضحا لا لبس فيه من رئيس
الوزراء باستقاله حكومتهم لا يكفي الحديث
عن مبدا تخلي الحكومه في غضون ثلاثه
اسابيع من بدء الحوار الوطني كما قالت
جبهه الانقاذ المعارضه بل يجب ان يكون
التعهد مكتوبا
امر وافق عليه اخيرا رئيس الحكومه في
وثيقه موقعه ارسل نسخه منها الى الرباعي
راي الحوار الوطني فبدات الامور بالتراجع
لم تكن الازمه الاخيره بين حركه النهضه
ومعارضيها من القوى ال ليبراليه ويساريه
وليده اليوم بل تعود الى نحو عامين ويزيد
لكنها ظلت تحت السيطره الى ان تم اغتيال
اثنين من رموز المعارضه مناهضه ال وصول
الاسلاميين الى الحكم وقادت الازمه تتحول
الى انفجار يهدد البلاد نفسها بالاجواء
ونشكر بلعيد في فبراير الماضي ولاحقا محمد
الابراهيمي في يوم فسارع معارضون الى
اتهام الحكومه التونسيه بالتواطؤ وفي الحد
الادنى اتهامها بالعكس وتساءل معارضون
بارزون ومناصرون لهم عن سر تكرار الهجمات
والاعتداءات على معارضين او على قوات
الامن بالتزامن مع جلسات الحوار المفترضه
اتهموا الحكومه ضمنا باستغلال ذلك لاضعاف
هم وتغليب الهاجس الامني على السياسي لفرض
شروطها لكن فيما تتهم به بل قالت انها
ملتزمه ب حوار شامل مع المعارضه ضمن خريطه
طريق واضحه فلا يمكن ترك البلاد للفراق
قبل استكمال كتابه الدستور الجديد وتحديد
موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
فذلك تفريط بالامانه لو حدث دون توافق
تحتاجه البلاد اكثر من اي شيء اخر
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشها مع ضيفينا من تونس
اما العزيز عضو المكتب السياسي لحركه
النهضه وشكره يعيش النائب في المجلس
التاسيسي لحركه نداء تونس
سيد شكري اه حسين عباس يقال هذا موعد مهم
في تاريخ تونس وكذلك
واعتقد هو اه بعض التحركات الميدانيه اللي
قمنا فيها طيله ثلاثه اشهر مباشره بعد
اغتيال الشهيد محمد براهمي وكانت هي
القوات الكاس لان اه اه من قبل هناك يعني
اشياء خلتنا يعني نفكر جديا حتى في
الانسحاب حتى من قبل يعني استشهاد ال اه
الزميل محمد البراهمي اه اه اليوم بعد
ثلاثه اشهر وصلنا حقيقه الى انتصار
الانتصار الاحزاب بالانتصار بتونس يعني اه
هي فوق الجميع فوق كل الاحزاب واليوم اه
ان شاء الله سندخل يعني حقب من تاريخ تونس
اه ح قبل تمكن انه تونس اه تجاوز كل
الخلافات الموجوده في اه الاطراف ال
المشهد السياسي ومن تعدي الام ال الامل هو
انه نعالج كل المسائل بما فيها الامنيه
والاقتصاديه
واه ال الارهاب اللي اللي ماكناش يتصوروا
انه انهار انه يوصل ويدخل الى ال البيوت
حاليا اه اذن ال الهدف هو الوصول الى
انتخابات منها يعني اه شفافه ونزيهه في
غضون بعض عشر اه سيد
راشد الغنوشي يقول اطار الخروج من الازمه
في تونس وضع على فكره اه الان اكثر هذا
الموقف
اه بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم من فعلا هكذا
نتصور جميعا في حزب حركه النهضه اه كون
اليوم في اشد الحاجه الى ان ننطق جميعا
نفس القطار نحن في حاجه الى وفاق واسع
والى اه اه اه اطراف ساعيه سعي جدي اقول
هنا واصر على كلمه جدا سعي جدي لانجاح
الحوار اي بمعنى انجاح
الانتقالي يعني المرور بس هذا هو القطار
فعلا هذه السكر سكه المرور من حاله من
حاله اه اه انتقاليه من حاله ال ال لا
دوله اه والنقل حاله عدم يعني استقرار
الدوله والمؤسسات والجمهوريه الى حاله
استقرار الى حاله بناء المؤسسات واستقرار
المؤسسات وبناء الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه التي
طالما حلمنا بها وتعذبنا من اجلها ودفعنا
من اجلها الارواح والدماء والشباب والغالي
والنفيس فعلا ان هي لحظه فارقه لحظه لحظه
يبدا فيها القطار يبدا فيها التعداد نحو
ال ال اللحظه التاريخيه التي تنتظرها تونس
تغييرها او ينتظرها شعب تونس بين ال اه
السيد اه شكرا لحظه فارقه اذن هذه اللحظه
الفارقه ما الذي يمكن ان يعكر ها برايك
والله احنا كلام لانه اه خريطه الطريق
الرب اي لقاء يعني احترامها بكل اه منها
معنى الكلمه يعني في اه في ظرف هذا
الاسبوع سنتعرف على الشخصيه التي تمكن لها
مهمه يعني قياده ال الحكومه في الفتره
القادمه بعد اسبوعين يعني اه تتمكن
الحكومه جديده اه سنتعرف على تشكيل
الحكومه الجديده والشرط ال الاساسي وان
تكون حكومه هذه متركبه من اطراف يعني من
شخصيات مشهود لها بالكفاءه والمهنيه
والحرفيه اه يعني مكه من كفاءه التنس ل اه
تقود وبالطبع
اخر هو انه كل الاشخاص هذه ستكون الحكومه
ليس لها الحق انها ترجح الى الانتخابات
وستكون هذه الحكومه يكون من اه على نفس
المسافه مع كل الاطراف اه بحيث اه ان تكون
حكومه مستقله باتم معنى الكلمه الحكومه
التي تعالج اه مسائل يعني حارقه
حاليا وصلنا الى مليون عاطل عن العمل اه
عن ميزانيه منها اه يعني عاده في
الميزانيه قرب ثلاثه مليار دينار اه
الميزان التجاري اه مقتل ثمانيه مليار
دينار يعني اه ولكن اه بالنسبه يمكن ان
تمتلكه هذه الحكومه المامول ان تشكل والتي
تصفونها بغير الحزبيه ولم تملكها الحكومه
الحاليه التي تعتبرها بحكم المستقيله هل
لديها سيكون عصى سحريه تحل كل هذه المشاكل
ان الوضع يسير ال ال اه من ال اه
هو انه يعني الحكومه ال ال ال ال الحريري
وحتى الحكومه ل سبقتها او المبدا حاولت ان
تسيطر على مفاصل الدوله تسيطر حتى على
اماكن العباده اه يعني اه تعيينات حسب ال
الولاءات الحزبيه يعني كل الاشياء ديه ثم
ثم من بعد مرحله العنف
تغطيه سياسيه
انه حكومه يكون تمشي على نفس المسار من
على اقل انها كل المسائل هذه ال ال
السلبيه
تذهب الى الابد والحكومه بطبيعه هي هي هي
نفس هي هي هي هي منها بسيط من الامل هي
يعني تعطي اه اه اشاره واضحه حتى الكويت
وحتى من المستثمرين الداخليه وهي
المستثمرين التفكير في الخارج انه
يتمكنوا يفكروا جديا ان الانتخاب يدعو
للانتساب في تونس ويمكن الدور الاقتصاديه
اللي تتحسن يمكن ان اه اه البلاد الى يعني
منها اه مكان مكان احسن
كل هذا هذا الشد والجذب والمشاكل والازمه
مع ما اعترفت ومشاكل اقتصاديه وامنيه
بالدرجه الاولى ايضا طالما في النهايه
قابل للعربيه بالتعهد كتابيا وانطلق
الحوار
نعم اه الشد والجذب دعاه او اه يعني سبب
ال ال ال كان داخلي او سببه هو ان هناك
اطراف في المعارضه لا تؤمن اصلا بالمؤسسات
يعني بالنسبه لها لاجل الوصول الى القضاء
وانا سمعت الى ضيفي الكريم الان وهو يقول
الى الابد وكان يعني اذا قرانا قراءه
نفسيه لهذه الكلمه وكانهم اصبح استقاله
الحكومه هدف في حد ذاته
يستميتون في سبيله يعني بال بال تحرير في
الشوارع وبالتحديد الاعلامي و بيشدوا
بالجذب يعني اه اه اه رجعوا للوسائل فقط
لكي
بالنسبه لي اعود الشيء الى اه اعقد قليلا
عن سؤالك للضيف وهو ال ال ال هذه الحكومه
ليست لها فعلا اه عصى سحريه نحن ننظر الى
حكومه حكومه اه اه تكون جهازا تنفيذيا
خلال الفتره دقيقه وهي فتره الانتخابات
التي ستكون في تونس في غضون الاشهر
القليله القادمه في العاده في اي
ديمقراطيه يعني عاديه اه اه اه لا لا تقال
الحكومه بهذا الشكل ولكن نحن كتعبير منا
ان حسن نيه رغم وجود هناك هيئه مستقله
عليا المصادقه عليها في المجلس هناك قانون
انتخابي المصادق عليه بالوفاق الكريم هناك
ايضا يعني مجتمع مدني قوي هناك يعني ملاحظ
من دوليون هناك كل الشروط مستلزمه ل اه
اتمام هذه الانتخابات في ظروف ولا
الديمقراطيه وسته ورغم ذلك وايمانا مني
بان تحتاج الوفاق تحتاج لمن يعطي لمن يغلب
المصلحه ارتاينا ان تكون هذه الحكومه
حكومه
تنظر
تصوروا في الشان ال التشغيل والتنميه وفي
ظرف الاشياء اللهم الا اذا كان يستقرون
بقاءها الى سنوات يعني وهذا هو الخوف
الكبير يعني
وجرح ما ما هو هو شرح ما لاسباب تحفظهم
ورفضهم لهذه الحكومه وكيفيه عملها
ويعتبرون ان طريقه عمل هذه الحكومه حكومه
العريض الحاليه او تونس الى هذه المشاكل
او لذلك استمرت هنا بين هلالين استخدم
تعبيره لكي يطالبوا برحيلها
نعم
حق المعارضه ان تقيم الحكومه كان شائك
وذلك ذلك هو دور المعارض في كل في الدنيا
في كل ديمقراطيه حقها انتقدها وان وان
تطالبه ان ترى ما هو اه احسن ولكن ليس من
حقك يا تقول هذه ال كاشفه او عليه ان
تستقيل الان هذا الشعب تقريره هذا الصندوق
كبيره هذه الانتخابات تقريرها كنت وهذا
يعني ان منطق المغاربه
انا اتكلم باسم الشعب ولانني اتكلم باسم
الشعب من حق ان اسقطت الان وقبل قبل
الاوان فلذلك منطق منطق المغاربه نحن نفضل
ومنطق التوافق منطقه شوارع لدينا به منذ
الاول نحن حركه تؤمن بالحوار وكنا منذ
البريه الاولى يعني حكومه حزب او كتله في
البرلمان نق من ان الحوار لا بديل عنه
ولكن في قطر المؤسسات والدوله لا خارج
المؤسسات اما ان تدعو تدعو الى ذلك خارج
المؤسسه تدعو الى حل المؤسسات
وكلما الانتخابات نعم سيد شكرا اذن منطق
المغالبه مرفوض هل منطق المغالبه هذا
سيستخدم ايضا كما تراه ال الحكومه الحاليه
او النهضه هل سيغلب ايضا في اثناء جلسات
الحوار الان وقد انطلق
اه اه انا نحب نقول كلمه بالنسبه لل اه لل
للوضع الحالي وخاصه منها للوصول الى
الانتخابات المقبله لا يمكن الوصول الى
الانتخابات المقبله في ظل اه انه ال ال ال
القضاء غير مستقل في ظل عدم الحياد الحياد
المائه العموميه في ظل يعني اه اه التعتيم
واه من
الاعلاميين
والفنانين في السجون يعني هذه الاشياء
اللي تخلي انه في ظل كيف منها يعني اه
السيطره على مفاصل الدوله والتعيينات الا
في الاداره العموميه يعني بال مستحيل انه
اه منها الوصل في الان الانتخابات الجيه
في ظل كيف العنف والارهاب يعني الحكومه ال
المقبله التي
التي ستعاني
انا اطالب منها انها ت تعالج كل المساله
يعني
اشاره الامل بالنسبه للتونسي الثقه
بين العرب وهناك الشيء اللي يمكن ان نصل
الى انتخابات بناها الذي
بالطبع بالنسبه للحيوان الوطني الحيوان
الوطني اه يعني كل الاطراف منها حاليا على
مائده الحوار واه ال اعتقد انه اه منها اه
كل واحد يحاول انه يقترب شيئا فشيئا من
الاخر بشكل
الحاله انتهى عدم ما اه يعني ت تتقلص نمشي
في نفس السفينه الى وجود الحلول ال ال
اللازمه باش نخلص بلدنا من الفتره الصعبه
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده احتمالات توصل
الحوار في تونس الى تسويه تحقق اذن
التراضي بين جميع الاطراف وتؤمن عمليه
التحول الديمقراطي
ام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش احتمالات التوصل الى تسويه للازمه
السياسيه في تونس تؤمن عمليه التحول
الديمقراطي سيد امال كنت تشيرين الى ما
سميته منطق المغالبه لدى المعارضه هل
تخشين من ان ما ترينه منطقا على هذه
الشاكله يمكن ان يعرقل التوصل الى تسويه
في اثناء جلسات الحوار الممتده هذه
انا شخصيا سيدتي الكريمه متفائله رغم كل
هذا الشد والجد الذي سبق هذا ال ال انطلاق
الحوار اليوم اه انا ابقى متفائله ونحن في
حركه النهضه متفائلون لاننا فعلا نؤمن
بضروره التوافق في هذه الفتره بالذات
شريطه ان اه اه اه تتوفر شروط اه اه اه
ال القطاع على ازمه الثقه ضيفك نتحدث
نتحدث على ازمه ثقه فعلا هناك ازمه الثقه
ولعل تعهد السيد رئيس الحكومه اليوم وكذلك
تعهد النواب وهذا معلومه
للمشاهدين تعهد ال ال ال النواب ال مسح ال
مسح بون عن جلسات المجلس الوطني التاسيسي
ايضا بالعوده و بمواصله العمل بجد مع
زملائهم المرابطون الذين لم ينسحبوا في
المجلس هذا ايضا من شانه ان يعزز الثقه
هناك يعني تعهد من كلا الجانبين كذلك لابد
من العمل داخل اه الشيعيه بما يعني يعني
هناك نظام اه اه داخلي ربما لا توافق على
تعديله في بعض نقاطه لكن لابد من احترام
كذلك هنا داخل المجلس هناك ايضا الدستور
الصغير او التنظيم المؤقت للسلط الذي يعني
حكم تونس منذ ال ال في هذه الفتره كلها
لابد من احترام ولا بدك ويكونوا يعني كل
هذا يكون في اطار احترام هذا التنظيم
المواقف الصلاه كذلك هناك شرط مهم جدا
لنجاح وهو احترام اه اه هناك يعني الناس
في المجلس الوطني التاسيسي لا بد يعني
هناك تتشكل تلك الايام ويجب ان نقرا عليها
حساب يعني كونه هي ايضا اه فاعل
داخل المجلس في لا بد من من محاولاتها
ولابد من الاخبار كي تمر ال الامور بسلاسه
الحوار بثلاثه كذلك فانا لدي هواجس انت
لديك هواجس لا باس ولكن لناتي معا نحترم
ما اتفقنا عليه منذ الاول في اطار الشرعيه
في واحترام المؤسسات في وضع احترام جميع
الاطياف السياسيه الموجوده داخل المجلس
التاسيسي لان اه اذا اردنا فعلا ان ان تمر
هذه الامور عبر القناه الاساسيه وهي مجلس
لابد من احترام هؤلاء اه اه اتصور واذا
توفرت ايضا امنيه جديه جنيه سياسيه يعني
هناك جديه سياسيه فعلا في الخروج من هذا
المازق اذا توفر هذا كوني متاكده ولكن
جميع متاكدون كونه
باذن الله لن نخرج من عنق الزجاجه على شرط
توفر النيه الصادقه وامنيه السياسيه
الجاده نكون جديين في اه اه اه ما نصبو
اليه من هذا الحوار ما نامل منهم الحوار
يعني
جانبا ندرك جانبا نعم
اشارت الى النيه النيه
اشارت السيده امال الى شرط النيه الصادقه
هي تقول علينا ان نخرج من الازمه شرط
النيه الصادقه تشير الى نياتكم صادقه
بالنس بالنسبه المائه
حاجه اشارتها الاخت ضيفتكم الكريمه انه اه
اول شيء اه في ال في الايام القادمه يتم
تعديل ال ال ال القانون المنظمه صوره
الدستور التغيير اه اه خاصه فيما يخص
المثال الحكومه تعرف انه م ستين ورشات
تختص ال المسار الحكومي في المسار
الانتخابي اه
بالنسبه لل مساله الحكومه يعني يتم تعديل
النظام المؤقت اه لسبب واحد هو انه مش
ممكن انه
سحب الثقه من الحكومه بالاغلبيه المطلقه
يقع التعديل لتكون الاغلبيه بالثلثين باسم
نقاش تلاعب بالحكومه الجرم حقيقه اتقدم
بكل اريحيه واحترقت لتكون اه هي بالذات
مشكله حكومه توافقيه منح بوش انه شو
المجهول يعني اول شيء
موجود حتى في خارطه الطريق بتحويل النظام
ال المؤقت للسلط العموميه او ما يسمى
بالدستور تغيير
هذه النقاط الدستور المصري الحكومه على
المسار الانتخابي باي من ال من هذه
العناوين من الممكن ان تشكل اه خلافا قد
ينسف جهود الانتقال الى المرحله المقبله
ولا الاراده الاراده السياسيه متوفره وفي
الاراده السياسيه موجوده وقت الثقه موجوده
اعتقد انه مثل ما حتى
انه يجب ان نعرفها والحل يعني كلها منها
كلها كل الاطراف اذكر تتفق على شيء يعني
يمكن تفعيله
كل شيء غالي
بسرعه
بسرعه كل شيء للاراده السياسيه لانه في
بالامكان حتى حتى يعني نهايه من عمل
الدستور حتى قبل اربعه اربعه وسبعين اذا
كان وقع يعني تحويل في النظام الداخلي وفي
النظام ال ال النظام المؤقت للسلط
العموميه
انت اشرت سيد شكري اشار الى الثقه وال
والاثنان اشرتم الى الاراده اذن ال
المشكله هي اكثر هي اكثر اه مشكله نيه
واراده وثقه ام انه الشيطان يكمن في
التفاصيل في اثناء جلسات الحوار برايك
اه فعلا التفاصيل فيها اشكالات في بعض
الاحيان لكن اذا اتفقنا منذ الاول كونه
الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل
على الشريط ان يعني احنا داخلين ليس
مسؤوليه ناس يبدو لي الناس المشاركين في
ال اه في ال في الحوار مسؤوله والمسؤوليه
تقتضي ايضا محاولات
قلب على الهوى الايديولوجي والاول الحزبي
ولا
كيف
سياسيه قائمه
بانها الايديولوجي والحزبي هو المسيطر انت
اشرت جيد انك اشرت الى هذا الامر كيف
تتخطون هذا الاتهام
والله يا سيدتي الكريمه لو اكس تي نحن لو
لو سمينا باسمنا بحركه او حزب جبر الخواطر
والتنازلات هكذا ندعي هنا هكذا تدعون
قواعدنا والمتعاطفون معنا وحتى الناس
العديد
كذلك
وصلتم الى حد ما اه اه الى هذا الحد
واضطر الابيض لل تعهد كتابيا بالاستقاله
كتابيا او الكتابيه الاراده موجوده منذ
البدايه سيدتي الكريمه منذ البدايه كنا لك
ان كان داخل نهايه الخوف على المسار
الانتقالي لم يكن يحكمون خوف على حزبنا او
على ذواتنا او بقدر ما يحكمنا خوف على هذه
البلاد وعلى مسارها وعلى ان هذا تضحيات
ابنائها ودماء شهدائها السودان وهذا كلفه
ذلك اردنا المحافظه على ذلك قدر الامكان
بتوفير الضمانات نحن اذا اذا اه اه
علمتم الدرس
المترين سيدتي الكريمه في كل كل الثورات
تعيش ازمات تعيش هناك ثورات مضاده هذا خوف
وارد جدا
المسؤوليه كسلطه وتحد من من مسؤوليتنا ان
نحافظ قدر الامكان عن
المحافظه عن هذا
تحول الديمقراطي الذي امانه في ايدينا
باختصار هل جبره النهضه خاطركم بهذه
الخطوه
سيدتي كل منهما تونسي حاليا هو شيئين اول
حاجه الامور امس الحريري
بالامان حاليا قاعده شوف الارهاب كل مكان
التونسي حاليا قاعده حتى اه حتى تشوفوا
شوارع العاصمه في الفيلا وفي المدن في
المدن الاخرى يعني اه كلها كلها فارغه
التونسي حاليا منها عنده مشكله هي القصه
هي ال القدره الشرائيه التي تبنت التوسيع
قيمه الدماء تونس يعرف اللي اه اه منها
التداول الم تعطون وصل الى حد ما يقال
كل المؤسسات العالميه لا تريد ان
تعطي قروض نعم انتهى وقت الحلقه ولم تجد
عن السؤال اشكرك جزيل الشكر على اي حال
شكري يعيش النائب في المجلس التاسيسي عن
حركه اداء تونس وايضا اشكر امال عزوز
المكتب السياسي لحركه النهضه ايضا من تونس
و اشكر متابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد من اللقاء
ام
نعم
هذا البرنامج